Vsauce! Kevin here. Kidsbeer is a soft drink
in Japan marketed toward children and designed
to look like beer. It's lager-colored, foams
like beer but tastes like cola and the slogan
states "Even kids cannot stand life unless
they have a drink"
If you need to drink a cigarette after that
there's liquid smoking. A Dutch relax drink
as opposed to an energy drink that claims
to give the drinker a similar feeling to having
just smoked. But it doesn't actually contain
any nicotine.
India has a soft drink made with cow urine.
The Hindu Nationalist movement, concerned
with the effects of American-owned cola drinks
on their youth created the cow urine soft
drink not only to lessen foreign influence
but because they believe cow urine helps purify
those on the bottom rungs of the Hindu caste
system.
Kumis is a central Asian drink traditionally
made with fermented horse milk. Unfermented
mare's milk isn't imbibed because it's a strong
laxative with 40% more lactose than cow's
milk and kumis is actually in its own category
of alcoholic drinks because it's not made
from fruit or grain.
Mamma Mia Pizza Beer is beer made from pizza.
During the beer-making process Margarita pizza
is put into the mash and steeped like a tea
bag - then the pizza spices are washed off
with hot water and filtered into a brew pot.
And according to reviews - it really tastes
like pizza.
Which would pair nicely with Water Salad - a
drink made by Coca Cola and sold in Japan
that is salad-flavored water - a beverage
that led Pepsi to respond with Ice Cucumber.
Bilk combines beer with milk. The Japanese
drink was created as a way to use up surplus
milk that was previously being thrown away.
A third of the low-malt beer is milk and they
claim that it has a fruity taste.
Snake wine is made by infusing whole snakes
in grain alcohol or rice wine. Found in China
and southeast Asia the belief is that the
essence and venom of the snakes dissolve in
the liquor to promote vitality. Other animals
infused in alcohol for purported health benefits
that range from improved eyesight to curing
the common cold include geckos, baby mice,
and sea horses.
China also has Magical Penis Wine and three-penis
liquor. Which uses three different types of
animal penises to supposedly boost the virility
of its drinker.
Yes.
And as always - thanks for watching!